tokyo's troubled olympic games have
suffered another setback with the
announcement that international fans
will not be able to attend
due to coronavirus concerns the summer
games were due to take place
last year but were postponed due to the
pandemic
now organizers have confirmed that only
japan based fans will be allowed to
attend
they plan to refund almost a million
tickets which had to be sold to
which have already been sold to
international fans dw reporter joel
dulroy has been following this and some
other problems surrounding the olympics
joel thanks for coming in
this decision not really unexpected but
it
did come with quite a literal shock can
you tell us more
there was a very illustrative moment
when during the meeting that led to this
decision
an earthquake struck off the coast of
japan and we can have a look now at some
images
of tokyo's governor speaking during that
meeting
as the quake strikes and you can see
here looking up at the furniture shaking
still quite composed now the quake was a
7.2 magnitude quake it
shook buildings across tokyo but it
didn't lead to any injuries or known
deaths so far
and of course the olympic committee will
be hoping for a similar
positive health outcome by making this
announcement in keeping international
guests out
in the middle of a global pandemic and
we can have a listen to
international olympic committee
president thomas bach
who explained that safety has to come
first
our first priority was is and remains
the safety of all participants
offered the olympic games and of course
uh
the uh japanese uh people uh we have uh
to take
decisions uh which uh may uh you know
need to
sacrifice from uh from
everybody
and there where we have to ask for the
understanding
there also of everybody for these
difficult decisions the ioc
president speaking about the decision
there now joel he mentioned sacrifices
how much of a financial sacrifice is
this going to be for japan
well they haven't actually announced how
much those 1 million tickets are going
to be worth
but i did some little calculations here
now previous analyses show that on
average olympic guests spend around 1
500 euros worth while traveling in a
host city
so that means japan is foregoing at
least 1.5 billion euros worth
of tourism revenue alone and these games
are already on track to be the most
expensive on record
however they had only sold around four
and a half million tickets now that is
less than the number of tickets that
were sold
for the last games at rio de janeiro and
way less than them were sold for the
london
olympics so this announcement might also
be a way of sort of saving
face and explaining away the empty seats
that we were already
we're going to see in those stadiums
also to mention while the ticket costs
are being refunded
travel costs are not so that's flights
that's hotels
so any fans who were hoping to go and
had bought tickets may be
doubly disappointed i certainly hope
everyone took out some very good travel
insurance
but this is only the latest problem of
many with this sort of
poison chalice games really if you like
tell us a bit more about that
so yes just days ago the creative
director of the games was forced to
resign after it emerged that he had
suggested a female comedian attend the
games
wearing a pig costume that became known
as the olympics
scandal and that followed previous
derogatory statements about women
made by the previous head of the games
who said that women talk too much in
meetings as a result
he had to resign so two key officials
are gone and there's another controversy
related to the olympics that you might
not know about but
the ioc has already announced in advance
that the host city for the 2032 olympic
games
is going to be brisbane australia now
that's my hometown
however well it's actually angered other
cities particularly some in the
germany's
rural rhine region now they were hoping
to make a joint bid for the games and
they are angered that the ioc has
ignored
the previous procedures of announcing
the winners of these games and
german politicians have said that they
will fight on to try and win those games
back
from australia so even though the
current host city is beset by problems
there are still
other cities around the world fighting
for the chance to host future olympics
well the battle between australia and
germany begins that is maybe not good
news for us
roy thank you very much for coming in
you